justin is with us in Indianapolis hi
Justin welcome to the Dave Ramsey show
hey better than I deserve what's up
alright so I'm sitting with a car
payment right now but I was offered in a
free car for my girlfriend's parents and
so I'm wondering if I should just turn
my car back in and take the hit of my
credit to have the temporary cash influx
now or the other way around okay so what
kind of car did your girlfriend's
parents offer you
it's a 2003 Honda Civic as a little mile
so the last a long time pretty nice gift
for the boyfriend long nearly fiance
okay all right and what do you owe on
your car almost 16,000 what's your
income right around 1,600 a month what
do you do I work in a factory okay 40
means 45 and 50 mm-hmm okay what's your
long-term plan I want to go to a police
academy right I'm 21 when you turn 21
how old are you 19
okay all right well you can't just turn
a car in and take a hit on your credit
if you do you have any idea what the car
is worth it's worth about four thousand
less miles
oh so you owe six million and you think
it's worth about 12
yeah that's what Kelly Blue Book says
okay if you turn it in you understand
they're gonna sell it on a repo lot it's
not going to bring 12 it's gonna bring
eight and they're gonna sue you for the
other eight yeah I understand yeah
that's not a good plan it's a much
better plan to go borrow the four
somewhere and sell the car
I'd rather you owe four thousand and
sixteen thousand drive the free Honda
and pay it off as fast as you can and
you don't take the hit on your credit so
you need to go see if you can scratch up
four grand or the other thing you could
do is you know you could deliver pizzas
every night for the next three or four
months and you'd have four grand extra
above your income or take on overtime
where you are or whatever but let's kick
it up to about sixty or eighty hours
where we are at 70 or 80 hours a week
doing something that pays really well
and get your four grand together and
then you get it sold but no I'm not
going to toss them the keys that's a bad
plan
hey thanks for the call